I'm joined today by Luke Vargas he is
the United Nations bureau chief for talk
media news he's joined us from all over
the world and today he is joining us
from Mexico City where he's been
spending a week learning about trade
immigration relations with the United
States let's start with the feeling
there Luke in terms of what Donald Trump
has been saying possible tariffs a wall
that he says at some point somehow
Mexico will be paying for what's the
general feeling there about the Trump
rhetoric here's a statistic that has
blew my mind and will probably blow
yours as well right before the election
public opinion firms here in Mexico
pulled the country and found that around
11 percent of Mexicans felt that the
us-mexico relationship was poor or very
poor that number is now close to 50% so
you've seen a tremendous change in
public opinion in this country moved
shifting negative about the United
States and that 11 percent is worth just
emphasizing it's near historic lows I
mean there is not a better time for
relations between these two countries
and that has changed dramatically it's
so bad now that I spoke to the CEO of a
leading market research firm here the
other day who said there is this
long-standing phenomenon in Mexico
called Malin cheese MOU it goes back a
long time and it's sort of it's it
explains sort of a preference on the
part of Mexicans for foreign products
and US brands have always been very
popular here and this man said the shift
is now very happening very rapidly and
whether consciously formally or
subconsciously informally Mexicans are
now turning away from American brands
and that's very important because you
have companies like Walmart making
billions of dollars a month here 711s on
every corner Home Depot's Ashleigh
furnitures you name it
Mexico for many American companies is
the second biggest overseas market for
them and for American public
you know Mexican public opinions to
change about the government but also for
American corporations is going to
undermine this America first narrative
that Donald Trump has been talking about
so from the newspapers to public opinion
there has been a big shift here people
just are
not having it at all with the rhetoric
of Donald Trump and what about in terms
of relations between the governments we
found that much of what Donald Trump
said he would be doing with relation to
the the Mexican government during the
campaign has not actually come to
fruition we've seen a meeting scheduled
and then cancelled between Donald Trump
and the Mexican president how are things
behind the scenes diplomatically if it's
possible to even know that I think there
was a hope and this is a hope shared on
the part of many people in the US and
around the world that Donald Trump might
be saying one thing but the people who
are actually implementing his decisions
would be on a very different page the
concern here in Mexico is really that
the bottom is going to fall out of this
relationship and in many ways it Mexican
government officials and legislators are
being pushed to do things which they
believe are going to harm Mexico when
you have 50% of the countries saying
they think relations are bad with the
United States and probably even higher
numbers saying they don't like the
government of Donald Trump then those
legislators are forced to introduce
bills interrupting the relations between
these two countries in a manner of ways
so that is one thing that is driving
these two countries apart you've seen
the threat of suspending law enforcement
cooperation between Mexico and the
United States another anecdote that I
think is very important to keep in mind
here is that in 2014 President Obama
asked Enrique Pena Nieto the Mexican
president to crack down on Mexico's
southern border essentially if Mexico
could keep Central American migrants and
asylum seekers out of Mexico in the
first place they wouldn't then be
traveling on to the United States and
Pena Nieto complied deportations I
believe were up to about a quarter
million last year alone and he risked
relations Pena Nieto with his neighbors
in order to do this thinking that the
administration in Washington would pay
him back for that and I'm sure Hillary
Clinton super president would have done
so there is now such a feeling of being
spurned that not only is this
administration not thanking Mexico for
probably keeping the number of people
passing into the United States lower
than it otherwise would have been
but Mexico is now singularly being
blamed for this very crisis so I think
relations are really souring on all
manner of fronts and it's so bad now I
spoke
to some financial advisors here who say
the u.s. is turning into a Banana
Republic
they're telling their Mexican
billionaire investors not even to bother
with the United States for the next four
years we've heard of CEOs having their
social media accounts looked into at
airports combing through emails
we even had a NASA scientist who had his
phone taken at an airport
obviously not Mexican in that case but
you know this is this is so bad now that
the the warning coming from those in
power here in Mexico - you know wealthy
folks - other members of the governments
to CEOs is don't bother with the United
States Mexico perhaps is the country
that will pick up the mantle of freedom
of expression freedom of trade but for
now we just do not trust the United
States at its core which is a very big
shift for such an important alliance
yeah I mean along those lines you have
some trumpets in the US who see the
so-called crackdown on Mexico as
something that will just be good for the
United States bad for Mexico period and
this sort of very black and white
clearly delineated a set of consequences
but it actually could be bad for both
Mexico and the US for the relationship
to go south couldn't it yes from Mexico
the financial toll is could be
devastating I think it's 73 percent of
exports from this country are bound for
the United States so any disruption in
that however minimal and looks like it
probably won't be minimal is going to
have a big impact then you start
thinking about people coming home if
there are large waves of deportees
arriving here back in Mexico that is
going to destabilize an economy that has
been on a very good trajectory in recent
years and that causes a problem which is
felt on both sides of the border which
is that you know crime has been on the
decrease here you have seen you know
good attempts in some states bad
attempts and others but generally a
correlation between low unemployment in
Mexico and a reduction in crime and if
you start to see hundreds of thousands
of people returning to a job market that
really doesn't have a lot of need for
more workers the number of opportunities
decreases and people may find themselves
looking for other types of informal work
or even you know becoming curious and
criminal and
surprises and that is something very
destabilizing for the United States
first what the US has to lose it's not
only that law enforcement cooperation in
barrel mine you know Mexican visa and
immigration policy as well as refugee
policy has often tracked that at the
United States for a reason so that the
United States could never say oh you
know terrorists could just be wandering
over the border because Mexico doesn't
let people in from many countries around
the world that the u.s. also is worried
about but of course now we've seen
Donald Trump saying terrorists could
just be wandering over the border so
Mexico is saying what is the point of
this cooperation and there are other and
just as one more quick anecdote about
how this could hurt the United States
look at an industry like corn I think
this has been talked about quite a lot
but Donald Trump always focuses on the
Rust Belt states bringing back
manufacturing bringing back 19th century
energy jobs in Appalachia and here we
have the prospect that the Mexican
legislature could pass a bill banning
imports of corn from the United States
well that this you know Mexico is the
largest export market for American corn
27% of all exports if that goes away you
have a new geographic region a new
economic portion of the United States
economy that could be adversely affected
and give Trump just another economic
challenge to have to confront so the
ramifications here just ripple out in so
many different ways look in the limited
time we have left nafta okay we've heard
from Trump a whole you know there's been
a whole spectrum of claims about what
he's going to do with regard to NAFTA
and Mexico
what what's really on the table right
now in terms of the NAFTA talks
well Mexico says they're open to
renegotiation I think they just want to
be seen as being a good faith negotiator
that they're never going to just oppose
something you know full-stop what's on
the table they don't they're not
interested in tariffs that's completely
off the table one area where I think
there is some flexibility is labor
standards wages these are things they
were going to sign up for anyways with
the trans-pacific partnership of which
they were a member during the
negotiation so they're probably willing
to take that language in maybe re
incorporate it into it you know another
NAFTA reboot also there's something
called rules of origin sixty two point
five percent of a product if it's made
within the NAFTA zone the product will
then be exempt from tariffs there is a
push in Washington to raise that perhaps
to 80 percent perhaps more Mexico would
like this in some ways because it could
mean that supply chains that perhaps
aren't a part of Mexico or North America
could come into this country but they're
nervous that the u.s. might push it that
they might say maybe 90% and in that
case corporations that rely on Mexico is
a key part of their supply chain might
not you just say attack with it let's
just do all our operations in Bangladesh
and maybe finish the product in the
United States and bypass Mexico so
they're willing on one hand but also
very nervous because this is a Pandora's
box you open up and after the process
drags on everybody wants input in this
agreement could splinter off into so
many different directions deportations
Trump I don't know that Donald Trump is
actually going to increase the
importation is relative to the Obama
administration in fact the plan that
represented at one point would would
extrapolate it out have a few a smaller
number of deportations happen under
Trump than what we saw under President
Obama but hypothetically if Trump were
to drastically increase deportations
from the Obama era what would that do in
Mexico
well and I think we are seeing with the
latest DHS instructions to the agency
that they are going to view all 11
million undocumented immigrants as a
priority now so those promises from
Trump may be off the table at this point
that we do need to wait and see there
are some sectors in this economy and
this is just a small caveat that
actually say they'd like some more
deport disease to come back people with
good bilingual skills people with other
various skills to go into the call
center industry to go into tourism to be
on cruise ships there's a desire for
those Mexicans who are in the u.s. to
come back home but that employment base
is going to be tapped out relatively
quickly there was an editorial here just
the other day that said if 10% of the
six million undocumented Mexicans came
back to Mexico it would inundate
government services and civil social
services we are perhaps looking at a
number much greater than that and this
government simply doesn't have a plan
pain a Nieto came in and was a president
seen by many as a puppet who would have
done well harmonizing relations with
Hillary Clinton you know keep everything
nice and easy going down the course on
the status quo he's not a president in
many people's eyes who is going to be
able to forcefully confront Donald Trump
someone who's going to be able to
radically reengineer the Mexican economy
to accept in all these people and
there's great concern that if all those
workers come back unemployment goes up
wages start going down and you have a
crisis in Mexico that may not be just an
immigration crisis but perhaps a refugee
crisis gone for bid on you know our
southern border which obviously the
consequences are very grave luke vargas
in Mexico City today United Nations
bureau chief for talk media news thanks
so much Luke thank you